What's up everybody!
So we have reached 100 000 followers
Which is absolutely amazing!
That's a huge milestone for us
And we just want to say thank you so much
For all your continued support
You are the reason why we stay motivated to
make these videos.
Yeah, and to celebrate this milestone
We have got this crazy challenge
From WhyBotherTry
Who wants us to play a rally
Using 100 different items.
Let's see if we can do it!
NO WAY!?
So that was probably one of the hardest things
we have ever done!
But we probably just broke some sort of a
World Record.
But anyway, once again thank you so much for
all your support
We are really happy to have every single one
of you watching our videos.
Y'all are amazing!
Until next time!